hey screw jockeys welcome to Oz trailer
commentaries we were talking right
before you start filming about what's
the name of that animated cartoon that
had Louie Anderson and it's you know
lucky Louie life with Louie no those are
all Louie CK Louie no dang it in the
comments below but we're here to talk
about the Santa Clause he's Spencer de
Gilbert why the lower thirds are flying
by that's Joestar no that's Dan Majerle
we did a honest thing about Sam cause
that's a weird movie isn't it -
hopefully you just watched the actual
trailer because we are going to talk
over the version we did give you like
more expanded thoughts about it and show
you some deleted scenes that didn't make
it in the final cut mm-hmm
Santa Claus let's do it every year we
ask ourselves what will we do for our
holiday movie we've done Love Actually
hmm we've done home alone Rudolph
we did Rudolph last year the great
extended song did the musical thing and
then this year I think we were between a
two but I think because there is a new
Grinch movie coming out next year we're
saving it for the new save and for the
new grants movie so I think we decided
on Santa Claus the Santa Claus with
Bendel back cumber bum bender Little
Snitch but yeah for now we revisited a
child classic the Sandy Claws where Tim
Allen starts off the trilogy kicks off
the franchise kicks off yeah who knew
that this would become a long-running
franchise where the first time you
become Santa Claus second one he like
needs to force so a wife on himself yes
yeah and then third one he has to like
you can give it up no yes it on like it
follows I think it's like you can quit
but then if you quit then whoever picks
up something and then Martin Short
becomes Santa Claus and it becomes like
a dystopia yeah he has to go back it's a
really complicated legal thing being
Santa Claus apparently so it turns out
so yeah that was my feeling just going
back and revisiting this is like this is
a pretty weird weird movie with like a
really weird mythos if you if you
scratch the surface of it yeah there's
something about Christmas movies where
they're all twisted and weird but they
just run through
go fast cuz they're all sort of polished
and everyone's smiling and there's
jingle bells sound effects like
throughout so you just ignore like all
the weird creepiness of their premises
so many of the mainstream Christmas
things are kind of dark and twisted the
Grinch and the Revue did the rankin/bass
things like those are really weird and
twisted and you know you have all the
huts set by the Christmas horror movies
like there is something even home alone
is really I'm alone maiming and injuring
people there's something kind of
strangely dark about Christmas well yeah
I mean even Christmas itself in the real
world is this like insane turducken of
like pagan ritual followed by like like
Christian early Christianity like
stapled on to it underneath like a giant
capitalist like let's yeah let's buy as
much as possible it's and then the war
on christmas is just orbiting around it
yeah what are you so it's it's a weird
turducken in the first place so the
movies are similarly weird but the
Spirit is all about giving and giving to
you so here's our trailer for the Sandy
Claws that we will now talk about as it
plays
[Music]
from the director responsible for all
things to Mao in comes the film that
actually went to imagine what if Santa
was real news what if he was a legally
binding curse and flickered on whoever
stole the pants off Santa's dead body
the Santa Claus this movie is why a
whole generation can't spell his name
I thought pause I thought it was the had
an e on there yeah this movie
single-handedly is responsible for
millions of people not knowing how to
spell Santa Claus my family's from the
old country and we really put the stank
on Klaus I mean even even it wouldn't be
called the Santa Clause even if it was
spelled with an e that's just a weird
phrasing like that would be calling it
you know the Dan Merrill the Iron Man
it's just weird
Iron Man or Santa Claus or Santa Claus
the movie which you should watch which
stars the actor played The Big Lebowski
David Huddleston and Dudley Moore as an
elf and John Lascaux as an evil
businessman and he makes candy canes
that make you fly okay watch it return
to the Christmas of 90s past
oh we're just like a pop star making a
half-baked Christmas album good edition
Joe and that Turtles Christmas some
songs from that correct we got to get a
gift for splinter right yeah and that's
the one where Leonardo's suddenly
Jamaican yeah I think Christmas
I think reggae yeah I think it'll
Christmas classics yeah all right let's
keep going Christmas albums at the
height of their powers would pump out a
half-baked Christmas movie that you link
is a Class A because you were a kid when
it came out and didn't know any better
meet Scott Galvez rear is jerk-ass this
guy Calvin and her jerk boyfriend over
custody of their jerk kid would you
please be quiet but when he fourth
degree murder Santa Claus he'll take his
job give it his own jerk flare do you
want this happen manslaughter the same
as fourth degree murder starting to look
like the Pillsbury Doughboy then loses
career clean legal record and son in the
process
happy holidays I guess and it go happy
on the first experience about the magic
of Christmas that sucks all the magic
out of Christmas where Santa isn't a man
but a job title
Santa died so often the rules of
succession are printed on his business
card and Santa's physique isn't a choice
but a virus that twists the hosts body
into a Santa sheep mask from which there
is no escape hm I wonder what would
happen if a woman killed Santa were a
child
or a dog I'm Santa Paws the body horror
element of this yes yes the fact that
this is a guy Scott Calvin he was it's
not like he was an evil guy like he was
it was a bit of a bore bo art but like
he was a successful businessman he had a
toy company but like a it's one of those
companies that only exists in movies
words like the ruthless toy company
drinking champagne you know no you know
and it's like he was he had his own
thing don't we had that doll like Debbie
Downer Dali or something like that yeah
that they didn't have to do anything or
something yeah I don't remember that
part out of my head it's you know it
wasn't like obliquely evil and you know
like he had a career and he had up a
house and go ahead all gone yeah I mean
here you have to assume the margin
there's that he was fired oh yeah
and so thanks camping on his record most
of the people in his life think that
he's a lunatic crazy person thinks he's
Santa Claus he's Santa Claus that
doesn't go away
some people know he's Santa Claus but
not enough and he's morbidly obese no
matter what he does stuff his heart
beats jingle bells like that's not
healthy that's really bad gonna get
nothingness in your fingers and totally
be like that and then he's gonna look 40
years older than he is forever
until he dies probably accidentally or
maliciously yeah and if he ever stopped
Christmas is dead for anyone until
someone literally Rob's his corpse yeah
yes like he can't stop eating like like
that office where it's like he can't
stop this is not a good so not a good
thing Christmas is really screwed up
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas I'm not
afraid to say it
all right Claus believe that therapy is
for losers Santa in psychiatry don't fix
he's not Santa where not only is all
mental health advice stupid but the
whole reason the hero believes in Santa
is to get revenge on his ex-wife for
dating a shrink well Neal's head comes
to a point go ahead dr. Miller I guess
we know who's the teacher's pet
Scott Oh grow up they charges you for
whoa holy moly someone's got some issues
to work on huh yeah feet short of a
stuff stocking yeah what is pan Scott
Calvin was not a fan of psychoanalysis
and really when you think about it
neither is the movie really bizarre
psychoanalysis is never vindicated in
this film it is it's kind of loses no
it's kind of like rubbing it in the
stepdads face then like you were wrong
your profession is a joke I'm really
Santa what now Mike
[Music]
it's awesome
mmm the whole like family dynamic is
really they've kind of write themselves
into a corner because like they can't
make the stepdad an outright monster cuz
then that's rough like if he goes off to
be Santa and like what it was made made
it easier well he didn't go off to be
sent but if like he gets his kid back at
the end round the monstrous stepdad but
like no one no one is quite monstrous in
this movie and so they're all just very
dickish yeah which you nailed with this
jerk this jerk this jerk this jerk
yeah the mom like starts getting on his
case about like you know looking like
Santa Claus and stuff like that at that
soccer practice yeah he was at and then
she shows up like he was here to see mom
sir but there's this weird thing and I
and I it's bothered me in this movie and
it bothers me even more in liar liar hmm
where Cary Elwes plays this like really
nice doctor yes who is very supportive
of martini and like is helping raise
their kid like Judge Reinhold in this
film and Jim Carrey is a jerk it's just
a real ass and at the end of the movie
Cary Elwes gets totally screwed over
because she's like well he's nice now so
sorry we were gonna support us but I'm
gonna go with my jerk ex-husband again
so it's like I don't care if you had a
magical wish that made you not lie and I
don't care if you're Santa Claus a jerk
is a jerk yeah and you know it but these
doctors always like what a lame-o like
Cary Elwes was like a but it like the
joke in that movie and it's like he
tries so we can't do the physical comedy
of Jim Carrey the intellectual comedy of
a Mel Brooks so there you go it's kind
of the same feel like Judge Reinhold is
really kind of just trying to make sure
that the kid grows up well-adjusted and
it's like hey this should be a nice
balance he's like what an egghead
what was this agenda 90s like this
either that guy just gets totally
screwed or he has to take unfortunately
this movie it's like that part of the
family stays together he's not like cast
off into the wilderness yeah like
they'll get totally screwed or the nice
guy like the script is like oh we have
to hate you now so they make this hard
right turn into just being like a
psychopath yeah I think it's more the
right kill board syndrome and yes was it
old-school
yeah it's the phenomena of like mid
nineties screenwriters and executives
all having broken families and yes
multiple divorces and therapy and just
like just all that resentment coming up
oh yeah what I don't think what I don't
think we see in the movie is that this
movie was written by a single dad at
that Denny's on Christmas that's a real
thing that's a real the single dad
Denny's Christmas mmm that's true though
it is movie after movie where the
high-powered executive is really the
good guy successful people that were
just too successful to keep a family
together they're like oh yeah yeah watch
this he's all about his feelings well
I've got a genius didn't put that in the
prenup
I love it starring Richard Carr to the
North Pole for a strange new take on
Santa's workshop with its own
paramilitary squad that operates outside
of human emotion trained to service
Santa's are weird sings it free range
and renard a cruel taskmaster who keeps
the workers toiling away through
stations excuse me are we on a coffee
break and we'll senators sexual
awakenings and for tells you how
desperate BuzzFeed is for cotton
because that was talked over by Joe Pete
now I think we need to roll that back
yeah what what yeah I was looking at the
actor and David crumpled David Krumholtz
this is the end and many many many
things I wrote a delightful song called
mr. Jones no that's that's the an
endurance similar look but yeah it was
um it was a big buzz feed on how Bernard
from the Santa Clause called my it
caused my sexual awakening and it was
like you think being buzzed for you to
be like a couple gifts and like that's
it but no it's like it's a long-form
piece and I don't know if I should get
in or reasons why here they were but
check it out for yourself if that
interests you
flexed and yeah it just tells you how
much buzz feed needs articles like now
like what else I just thought it was
weird that he was the only like teenager
yeah
North Pole like does that denote
authority I guess
strange dishes decision to like make
them children I don't know yeah
perpetual children is was weird to me
that they had like dating life she's
like I'm dating so-and-so I'm seeing
someone in customer service like a
vampire thing keep buying Christmas they
turned her to no way this place has a
union so revisit this 90s do that job
every one of it from kids fantasies that
Santa is real parents fantasies that
their children will respect them the
studio's fantasies that this movie
deserved a trilogy and Tim Allen's
fantasy one of a closets to be corrected
please interrogation name Morse measure
unlike you know what actually happened
look it up stay tuned to this right
styles they get all BJT t know
and the pimp from true romance grow
great psychiatrist one day kid no you're
not family business so you're gonna kill
your dad
that is the business it's the liking to
think - this is like I can't wait to be
king well your father has - yeah that's
what happens that's how Kings work
actually Rome right into deleted scenes
yes let's do it
we have some a debate that we would like
what would happen if a woman killed
Santa or a child or a dog what have you
just slipped in the bar so does this so
become Santa Paws yeah unlike yeah I do
like via the soap because the rules are
whoever kills Santa and puts on his
pants become Santa Claus and you see
that it takes your body over so does the
soap nut talk is it like they have a
theory you know I have a theory that
whomever discovered the unfortunately
mangled body of Santa Claus and then
retrieved his clothing would then become
Santa right but what if if he slipped on
the soap and then their soap banks off
something goes inside the pants the soap
acknowledge or choose that you are
putting here's my question let's go back
to the source let's go back to the Old
Testament or wherever Santa Claus
actually started what came first did the
paint chip ssin book of the dead the
pants fall from a meet like were they a
part of a meteor and someone found the
pants and put on the pants and that's
the beginning of the curse yes that the
source of his power it is a sentient
pair of pants it's it's like Menem is
it's Adam
the Santa hood of the Traveling Pants
inside one meteor were this venom
symbiotes
the Santa pants and Pennywise the
dancing clowns all simultaneously
crashed on the planet oh that's a
universe I'd I'd want to yeah
[Music]
yeah and if you so if you put the pants
on a baby the baby would look it would
have the mind of an infant but the body
yeah by Santa Claus rule I think you
just spits the holiday classic baby
Santa which probably already happy right
screen turkeys 2017 we set it on this so
it must be ours
okay so that was that digression looks
as if an AI room but like rolls into the
Santa pants yeah the apps tuck closet we
just put your phone into it Oh God
sent a baby starring Alec Baldwin yes
yes great yeah
that's the boss baby special yes holiday
special real life when he got most it
with 650 grams of cocaine and not jail
time by snitching on its fellow dealers
over half a kilo
that's no pause pause and we debated how
much to put in here cuz I find the story
fascinating there's so much here that I
clearly just wanted to talk about this
and unfortunately we were doing a thing
about a movie but I'd really rather just
talk about yeah Tim Allen's sort of past
where he's his name Timothy real name
Timothy dick in the 70s was moving so
much cocaine 650 grams could put like a
size on that like that's that's a brick
right that's a brick of cocaine then
again like I don't think I would have
brought it up in the trailer but I think
semi famously he avoided going to jail
for life by turning over all of I guess
Milwaukee's or reveries from all of the
like local joke scene where you got the
coke from who's the player here who's
the player that I'd watch this Fargo
season by the way and then in the movie
multiple times they have him being like
I'm not talking see you have to wonder
if this was a Tim Allen like conscious
or subconsciously like trying to make
amends or or kind of block out hey guys
what if there was a scene where the
police just interrogated me and I just
I didn't give up anybody so yeah I guess
what I'm trying to say it snitches get
stitches names out the street I don't
know we cut that because obviously it
goes too far but you're watching this
video so you get to see it anyways there
you go I'm learning now that really why
bother cutting anything anymore because
it's not like it just sits on a hard
drive like it used to
yeah I will cop to leading the perhaps
that's to know as well you should have
rolled it back as well as I was trying
to force in something about how Tim
Ellen said that living in Hollywood as a
conservative is like being a Jew in
1930s Germany for that can I can I ask
this though is your obsession with this
story where the excuse of next year came
from just one okay when you know real
real talk with celebrities I find it
fascinating this in the end Mark
Wahlberg would have stopped 9/11 early
for whatever reason so that's worth a
look up yeah yeah
there's something about it just being
Tim Allen yeah exactly like the guy
would have expected to be selling that
much cocaine it goes to show you the
difference between a pre-internet and a
post internet culture yeah as far as
having easy access to history and and
and the the spread of it yeah
cuz that would he was that he was the
face of the family the the family who's
a piece of family in America ten years
yeah yeah yeah so there you go there you
go
life's little oddities alright let's
finish out with some alternate funny
names even for Santa that's a lot of
snow story John is a good grind budge
Weinhold
okay Beverly Hills stepdad Beverly skip
daddy's home a sentient acorn he just
looks like a Conan Berg's a Christmas
story but we all had that bull cut yes
yeah we did I did I know I did yeah so
we could bring in our acorn photos next
week yep we've had janked up teeth in my
giant glasses yeah do we get
I think we all have the exact same look
I'm pretty sure at my we below uniform
on to for that school picture you're my
Boy Scout uniform my parents went all in
on that year they were like you know
where your Boy Scout uniform for school
pictures and I was like well oh wow I
thought you just called me a fake anime
fan now man you go you go Cub Scout we
blow boys Kappa
we balloons yeah I never got to we blew
I was I come Scout and I was just like
I'm good all right yeah
so in conclusion none of us covered bard
Scout 4 okay cause several times and may
we never speak of it again until we do
the second and third ones which I'm sure
will get to the next Christmas I hope so
next week is pretty predictable I think
there's a Star Wars movie out next week
right yeah okay yeah sure I think if you
track us to do together yeah yeah pretty
easy to put together
but Wrath of Khan yep Brassica see you
next week bye guys
[Music]
you